go
welcome back to you again yeah it's a
crush on you oh he's a pleasure welcome
back to the gentleman's bow yeah do this
to my left from Detroit Michigan Motor
City Motown ah the city where it's kind
of defunct have you embody that listen I
would like to think I'm bringing some
life back into the city I think people
from my high school look at what kind of
career I've had and little envious okay
uh to my left Gary cannon comedian not
really your warm-up comedian writer
comedian yeah yeah we you wouldn't call
yourself a comedian well you gotta tell
you last week we had on before I
introduce you but last week we had Frank
Caliendo on he was talking about trying
to impressions all this other great
stuff and he told me whenever he walks
into a room when he's doing stand-up and
there's not a lot of people there he
feels that's his impression of you to my
right from pittsburgh PA it's so uh no
it said he's your the horse dude ah to
my right from pittsburgh PA Steve bam
bam firm I guess why do you say like
yeah well I don't know I thought my joke
was better than you're giving it credit
for I gave you an awesome introduction
okay back it up edit what's the time
code great to my right from Pittsburgh
Pennsylvania getting ready to record his
fourth hour special Lincoln Hall Chicago
two shows steeper that was actually a
good introduction yeah thank you I I
know when you're getting pissed when
we're doing stand-up and I well we were
at the lawyer comedy store a couple
weeks ago and I brought up Gareth
Reynold saying you may recognize the sky
from different strokes he played the guy
that violated that molested ugly it's
immensely yeah at the back of my
shopping dude i just i left the
microphone just walked out Gareth was
right behind me yeah and then Gareth
goes up he's like I never molested
anybody out and yeah that's always a
good haul i wanted to mention this uh
when we had Frank on the show and just
didn't get a chance to when we were in
La Jolla right we were all staying at
this condo that the the comedy store has
right by the beach which is great so it
was meet you Gareth was staying there as
well who was working with us on the road
and a buddy of ours a Jason
dallas you came down to take some video
of the show and so Gareth goes out to
hang out with some friends during the
day and it's me you and Jason that are
sitting in the condo mid afternoon on
Saturday watching some football I'm
laying there and you say hey get up
we're gonna go outside on the beach and
play football I say I have absolutely no
interest i'm gonna lay here watch the
football game and you say very nicely
get up fat ass as you told me you say
get up five yes you need it you need
exercise and I said who the f are you
i'm gonna lay here you're not my mom i'm
gonna lay here so then you shut the TV
off right and you say let's move it so
then i'm being a team player I go
outside right Gareth joins us it becomes
two on two football me and you at first
right you're getting angry because I'm
just making fun of everything and
goofing around up being serious and you
you're taking it very seriously like
it's a super bowl you're not true yeah
better No so we end up we're getting our
asses kicked I then switch teams it's
mean Gareth versus you and Jason and and
say this we smoked you guys smoked would
be mo q god I don't think so there was a
period where was it was the Marcia Brady
episode where you threw a football
rating my tag you right in the face
right in my face well I was trying to
hit you in the back and you turn around
at the wrong time and you looked right
into it are you so trying to hit me I
mean it doesn't matter where you were
trying to throw I know I didn't try i
hit you yeah i enjoy i'm not gonna lie i
did enjoy cuz there's that moment where
you do something on accident and you hit
somebody go oh i hope there but you
can't stop laughing right i couldn't
stop laughing it but I did how many
times did I ask you are you okay you did
ask me if I were if I was okay and all I
said to you I said I don't want an
apology all I want you to admit is that
you don't sell tickets for me that was
more rewarding than any type of apology
I was like just pleased now you don't
sell any tickets and the fact that you
didn't say it it still meant the world
to me that i know inside that you don't
yeah which was great it was packed the
whole weekend that went that one that I
was counting the empty chair the back
that's like 1230 friday late show friday
first show i think it was for shoka by
yourself care yeah there were a lot
empty seats oh we had a good time wait a
good time today I'm very excited we have
a very special guest calling in yes
and just let us know when he when he
calls in he is a co-creator Chapelle
show yeah great stand-up comedian and
he's also got a wonderful podcast on
this network on all things comedy called
the champs I'm so excited about Neal
Brennan yeah Neal Brennan is a guy that
I knew from back in the day he and I
used to do like late night spots at the
Boston comedy club which doesn't exist
anymore but it's like your career it's
great by the way with neil too because i
mean i remember you told me a couple
weeks ago you're like hey Neal is going
to be calling in today I'm ever you told
me that began in January cycle it's
awesome that we did you booked him so
I'm excited for that so um I think he's
on the phone right now Neil how are you
hello Brennan doin how are you good to
have you bud good you're here with
myself and Gary cannon how are you bud
I'm good I don't think I know Gary can
do I I know you don't neither does the
industry Gary actually did the audience
warm-up for Sullivan & Son he did it for
kilbourne for Ferguson yep for uh for he
does it for Conan right now I'm like
sounds like he is the kiss of death well
not whoa whoa yeah no I agree with you I
know I show I did a show that Neal was
on this is where you and I met Neil it
was a little show that we taped over at
CBS on The Price is Right stage called
short comms of course never bored what
the is yes Gary I got another kiss
of death yeah man well maybe look at
your backyard what we lookin mind roll
Bieber I will I don't hear what you said
like nice tease technology blog that's
great i will say that i would contend
that my short com was the best but he
wants how much your wise i mean i
was sure come mr. Cobb was the thing
that Fox tried to do a few years ago
where they had people do short sitcoms
like 15 minutes sitcoms your 12 minutes
to come and so and they had a bunch of
them in a row it was the idea of a
shortcut was good but they had literally
four of them in a row so i guess like
old-fashioned like moving
sets like a live TV broadcast incredibly
weird talking my I walked my show and I
thought I was good as his sitcom actor
yeah up davidoff did one Ali Wong
michael kosta it was hosted by craig
robinson and I member / Neal they didn't
even have set changes but they basically
just switched the projection on the
screen like behind the whatever it was
it was like there was a there was a
there was a much i a'n't LED screens and
they would like for the coffee shop sat
on there and then you'd sit in chairs
and do the same it was pretty crazy yeah
it was interesting out is that one is
that one of the net were you were you
writing and creating your own short come
right in creating and starring in my own
short time and yes the word starring is
correct because I now what is it you're
working on now Neal where what what are
you working on now currently because you
always have something in the mail a line
I was got something in the in the hopper
um in the last month i believe i
directed 12 commercials Jesus that that
have yet to start airing venom but just
even carry on the Super Bowl oh nice
well you you is that part of a Nike
campaign that you were directed because
you're no not liking okay not like you
well a lot of company a lot of people
know you or or associate you or or have
heard your name being co-creator of
Chappelle's Show prior to you calling in
I was discussing with Gary that I've
always known you as a stand-up comic arm
but you had been working on Chappelle's
Show prior to being a comic when did you
decide to make the leap into stand-up
the leap um I don't know if I decided to
make the leap yes I'm still waiting for
the industry to help me make the leap
the i guess like apt i did a little bit
during the show and then afterward I
started really in earnest in two
thousand
seven which is too which is late like
you shouldn't start in your 30s so I try
to tell the kids don't start anything in
30 I mean whatever is most of what
personal most of people who make it in
show in comedy and jibbitz started make
it in their 20s and be you what are you
doing in 20s really dictates the rest of
your life so so so yeah thankfully I
also in my 20s direct mind I guess I
didn't direct stuff in like I did yeah
actually the first thing I ever directed
was on my 30th birthday the first thing
I ever like officially directed so but I
spent my 20s like I wrote half a good
day when i wrote movies and stuff like
that so I did do I was in Chavez how
tough is it to make the I don't know if
you call it the break but it but you
know your own name for yourself after
Chappelle's Show you know Dave and you
kind of go your separate ways and you
start working how difficult was that for
you are how how gratifying was it for
you to break that association and just
come out from under that umbrella and go
now there's another guy here too as well
I still think it's it's ongoing I don't
think it's like done I don't think we
were like you know if I walk down the
street with Dave no one notices me if I
walk down the street by myself a couple
people will notice me so like I don't I
think it's on oh I think I have to make
like have you do something significant
enough that people go like oh which I'm
working on that you know like this short
come if that would happen that might a
banana or I'm show now a piloted amazon
hopefully that'll go all right i'm doing
a show of one man show New York studying
februari sixteenth called 3 mics but
hopefully that'll be popular it so you
just have to keep I mean I don't Dave
before he made it used to say like I
just feel like I'm chipping away at a
big rock right and then
for like you know it's like trying to
break out Shawshank you just dig and dig
and dig and dig and dig and at some
point like like there's nothing behind
the long like oh i'm gonna make it
i am you know i love maybe it doesn't
maybe never have you never know well I
don't spend too much time talking about
the past I do want to ask you this
though what was the most proud sketch
you did on Chappelle's Show what is your
baby that you look back on now even and
say that I mean that was that's
the uh there's a bunch of extras
like that obviously the popular ones
work James and the wine white
supremacists are really good and in
there certain more obscure ones which
one where Dave's shows how his family
has always been sort of a getting sort
of contrarian RAM and it's like a bunch
of flashbacks to like different times
like him and his it's him in the fifth
of him and there's 90s him in the 70s
him in the 50s him in the head blazek
tracing it back to slavery and that's
good one there's another only day we
should write it could never be it he'd
be a bad he'd be down on a jury because
he seems to be the shadow of doubt is so
huge for black people just because of
how shady the justice system it's been
forever so that's another lie that's
another so he testifies like I'm kind of
on behalf of OJ on behalf of Michael
Jackson ami high polish kid right and
then I gotta excuse why is that this is
the last question I'll ask you about
schapelle sure why does that show still
resonate because you can still turn on
the TV and see repeats of that show III
put out a tweet like recently where was
like thursday at eight o'clock and
they're showing Chappelle's Show I'm
like this show still kills it that
they're airing at thursday at eight
o'clock on cable I mean why is that show
just transcended and is still relevant
even after all these years has been on
like 10 years well thankfully the
justice system hasn't improved for black
nothing that i'm targeting i'm gonna not
know you're wrecked yeah like so that's
been that's always kind of liked because
it's all the same issues and it's more
or less the same people doing like it's
more or less the same and you know it's
the diskettes are well written and well
shot and Dave's a giant star like it's
fun to watch them it's like just it will
never will never get tired of watching
Dave do stuff and he haven't done
anything else so it's sort of all it's
like the only artifact left right um of
his sort of shabbos yeah um I gotta ask
you so so the show ends and everybody
knows the story and all that stuff and
then you it seemed to me like you delved
deeper in his stand up and then I think
maybe this is two years ago you did a
Comedy Central our special called women
and black dudes and I personally I just
seeing at the comedy store work on it
watching you knowing you all these years
I personally would put that in my top
ten of all time and I'm not saying that
because you're my friend I'm not saying
that because we've known each other for
a lot I truly believe that how how was
the experience of going from chappelle's
show to your own stand-up special what
were the thoughts going through your
head prior to and then even during it
prior to you know I mean prior to you
just try to get the show right and then
during you know I guess doing it was
like just trying to get it just trying
to perform stuff well cuz I know how to
write jokes again what that's have not
not I'm not like that no problem so for
easy they're not easy but they're not
that like when it comes to performing
that's more of a challenge so just
trying to be a good performer mm-hmm I
literally have to like run by myself to
smile on stage and I give a robot
did stand up with like smile robot all
right and huh so so there's that and
then I remember my my girlfriend at the
time when I got off stage this was a
testament to why do I she wasn't going
to work when I got off stage I'm not
special she said man those people love
you not yours ladies Christ if they're
just that you tripped those people so
yeah that's pretty great but yeah so I
appreciate you saying that I think it's
very good I it doesn't it's not in like
that you know it doesn't people don't
really it's not like a renown would have
been known something but I've but now
it's not a recognized top 20 by anybody
else but I other things really good I
think it's great and look if you get a
chance go to look go to itunes download
it you can rent it it is absolutely i
think just on par with any of the great
writer comics that are out there that
aren't just relying on physicality or
whatever but you definitely have a very
clear perception of the world and a
strong opinion i obviously that's that's
the backbone adding comedian but it's
something I've always appreciated about
you and love watching you grow are you
work that night stuff like the big leaf
or the Ramona truths which is really
nice now are you working on it on a new
one currently or is that the Middle's of
the really nice thing is the pre Mike
thing is this show I'm doing that it's
basically like because people are so the
first off there's so many hours now
Ryan's got an hour and so I mean there's
a guy named Steve Bernal I think since
four of them still can't sell tickets
Carrie I'm talking anneal and so I'm
just trying to figure out a way to like
because I was like I thought that our
was good and no one seemed to care and
so I'm going to do another hour at this
hour is I
if the sheriff's caught three mice
because I put three mics on stage one is
for stand-up one is for one liners that
I've never been able to put anywhere on
my act if you're just one liners and
they don't relate to anything and in the
middle mike is for like true personal
emotional stories right that are looking
necessarily funny too funny ish but
they're not like stand up honey so so
I'm doing that in New York starting
every 16 and I'm going to do it on some
network to be negotiated okay okay now
how difficult is that worker to
understand the Jenga or to put the
puzzle pieces in correctly because when
you hear of it there's three different
outlets for comedy when do you know to
parlay this heavy-handed perhaps deeply
personal story and then jump to that one
liner or then go to that stand a bit
like how long did the process I only
bury it I only switch Mike's three times
let me know but not 3 times total but
like I do i do like I do basically 10
minutes on the first two mice in the one
line I'm like summer like three minutes
right so it'd take 10 10 3 10 10 3 10 10
and the show's over Ilan's and then like
11 liner show's over so so I guess it's
like figuring out I it's basically like
good anecdotes in the middle or are like
there's an art to that they're just just
talking about that I dealt with
like depression and sure like that and
and then stuff with my father and then
the stand-up is just sort of like it
that's good enough right right enough
that's enough good jokes for that period
well another one liners are just little
edge picking a random now I gotta I'm
looking forward to seeing that I cannot
wait to see it again you're one of my
favorites and I'm not saying that again
good friends but I truly mean that ah I
gotta ask you this
uh maybe people know this maybe people
don't but you you actually directed a
feature film called the goods the Don
Reddy story starring Jeremy Piven a good
what worthy what were the pre
preconceptions going into a thinking
this is going to be this kind of comedy
and that will how did the aftermath of
the film whatwhat came about for you in
terms of your experience yeah I reckon I
sure was pretty much any opportunity I
had before dried up which was very
exciting the basically like it was the
preconceptions were exact what I thought
which is making a movie as a Hollywood
studio movie take an eight million
dollar movie or whatever is a it's a
very big bet you're betting that gets an
all-in bet you can't really make small
bets when you make a movie keep like you
will get all the credit all the blame
whichever and in my case is blame right
the forensic that maybe was Jeremy felt
it was the scripts for it was my fault
who knows but we all got blamed and
that's kind of just the way I knew that
going in and it turned out exactly right
it's you have to get lucky in a lot of
ways like you have to get the culturally
lucky you have to get like you know the
movie has to be about something that
people care about it has to be about it
has have all the way people in its have
a good trailer I think the biggest
thought was people don't really know is
about and people don't really care about
use car shall see what I wanted to do it
because we'll Fatima k produce it my
love live death right like they're my
favorite you know they're my favorite a
probably comedy writer star team and
like McKay just directed the big short
so he's nominated for three Oscars like
he's a brilliant guy so forget so I want
to live with those guys and that
whatever the movie just didn't take for
everything and I've not been allowed
back
uh would you uh I don't have it come off
as brash but professionally speaking
would that have been the biggest hit or
or failure on your resume are the
biggest threat now because it's gonna be
special but I I meant I meant hit to the
resume in terms of that not not like you
know we are greater threat oh yeah
absolutely well only when I'm not even
being like I don't think you're being
like Oh Stephen you're being brash like
I know exactly what is I don't even try
to I don't shrink from I'm just like
yeah yeah I made a movie people didn't
see much you can't you're not allowed to
do that really not allowed to do it and
make movies they will stop wetting you
make movies what was the biggest lesson
I guess in the aftermath of it that you
that you took away from the failure of
of the film I guess that just don't make
a movie unless you really really give a
about don't do it because of one
element don't do it because another
don't you know just do it because you
really really like it and you really
really it what you feel like it'll work
and you don't have to squint to see it
and also just having some say in the in
how it's how it's made how it's marketed
how its cast all that stuff like I you
not like you need to absolute say but I
just I guess i wish i had more right um
so so yeah but you know i don't see this
as like like a big I don't know it just
doesn't it's so absurd right i don't
really even see it at like a I know it
doesn't bother me that make sense of
course yeah I I gotta ask you because
you're so known of collaborating with
Chappelle and just in being in terms of
being friends with you you've worked
with everybody though in the comedy
world like you've literally worked with
so many people is there somebody still
on the radar that you would love to sit
down and collaborate with that you have
not yet
Eddie Munster want to really work with
he pitched the sketch one time that we
used but I'd like to I'd like to I mean
he's a guy that like he has a movie that
it's being written right now but I'm
really trying to get involved in and
either as a rewrite their director or
whatever like he's just like he's
amazing and a really good dude and
always very nice luncheon I gotta ask us
when I Chapelle show is just
skyrocketing and this is a classic your
candid question but what is the one
thing like were you were you finally
like I'm gonna treat myself it's time to
spoil myself what was the one thing that
you got for yourself where you you know
you finally had money to atlanta gary
cailin gasket textbook classic vintage
canon um what did I I guess the thing I
bought was an apartment that's that's
pretty awesome but is in New York City I
assume right yeah do you still own it ya
know I end up losing money on it and
i'll tell you why let this be another
caution for kids when you buy a
penthouse apartment in New York a lot of
them week because apartment because
billing does because that flat roofs no
flat roof and it leaked and I couldn't
actually lost money on the resale
because I couldn't it was the ceiling
also objected well Gary rents so he's
not gonna take that out that's why never
bite when Steve got there yet Sullivan &
Son he went to the 99 cent store and
splurged okay unless I can you think
that's the biggest comedy embarrassment
at the comedy store Neil the Sullivan &
Son show people don't want to talk about
it but I'm willing to bring it out like
nobody wanted to be part of that show
did they wanted wanted we wanted to be a
part of it like if state like Steve came
into the comedy store like one night you
news working on the show like people
would make eye contact with him because
people thought that he might add
than to be a guest star like just nobody
okay you have to pay now this is scary
this all just Gary being Gary sorry oh
he's never heard of you and that's
exactly I guess I'm sorry I just Michael
to be why keep them on on the show why
c'mon vodka why I question myself yeah
all the time yeah carrying this thing uh
oh for sakes um Neil I cannot
thank you enough yes and we look forward
to seeing your Super Bowl commercial and
take too much your time but i I've been
wanting to have you on for quite some
time and I'm glad it worked out and yet
people live in the air can go see the
pre Mike's which will be the Bleecker
Street dealer what what is the date
started 15 februari 16 3 mics Neal
Brennan and is there a website that they
can go to or do you know that or my
there is not one yet Stephen okay well
be on the lookout for it one of my
favorite comics and Neal I cannot thank
you enough for spending the time with us
and look we're on all things comedy
listen and yet podcast the champs it's
awesome ah nice again buddy i really
appreciate a pal okay okay thanks hail
that was Neal Brennan you should love
him a show called no Mike's one mic for
each audience member anyway I'm so glad
that Neil remembered because we booked
him at the very beginning of january and
i'm so glad he remembered this date and
remember to call in sometimes comics get
aloof and they forget what is uh should
we giving away all mics well hold on
Steve I relax Jesus Christ um we we have
a sponsor this week region by the way
you were great in that interview I mean
the way you jumped in and has some real
questions and I mean this guy has done
at all in terms of comedy been part of
the zeitgeist of the country when
Chapelle show was on and you had nothing
to ask you are an absolute by the way
parachute online is a bedding brand
based here in Venice Beach California
and I will tell you something Steve you
at one point had comfortable sheets and
I remember them at one point that
weekend that you were in richmond
virginia on the road um very bushy and
just know this stephen as neo would call
you great sleep starts with your sheets
and parachute has created an online a
website with great bedding essentials
from sheets two comforters to give you
of the superior
a sleep that you need because that's
very very important parachutes website
is very straightforward you can get
through it very very quickly they offer
a free shipping free returns and a 30
day 30 night a risk-free guarantee so if
you don't like them you can return them
now here's the great thing Steve you're
not gonna believe this III can't wait
listen I can shop online and go to
parachute home com backslash dojo
mentioning our website mentioning our
dojo you will get twenty five dollars
off your very first order isn't that
great that's pretty awesome ash yeah
people don't know this like a lot of
people sleep without a top sheet and
that's a not comfortable yeah so I'm
just telling you people that they need
to add the parachute website it's a
great could you say the website one more
time uh parachute home.com I'm in
parachute home com um yeah I'm gonna do
that I I think I'm gonna surprise my
wife yeah with some new sheets are you
relly I swear to god yeah oh really yeah
i think when you do like those little
things like that shirt that there is a
big deal like to a two woman that's like
you got new sheet and and actually i
would lay them out and like you know
tuck it under the mattress CJ good job i
do a good job with it cuz right now I
just I just like throw it on like like
that parachute thing and fifth grade in
the gym class yeah yeah chuckle a guy
but yeah would you use this website
parachute home com I'm going to yeah
yeah me too I'll do it well backslash
dojo backslash dojo yeah if you use
backslash champs that's thirty percent
off okay Stephen I gotta tell you I mean
that Niall interview was great i love
that guy and uh we will obviously do
some heavy editing the show um but
everything was good I liked it and
obviously they can see you thanks
everybody for listening we appreciate it
hey my god sorry I'm just iced tea women
in black dudes dong honestly do yourself
a favor rent women and black dudes I
love the album Neil is one of my
favorites I think you'll enjoy to at can
and calm it down at steve byrne live and
we are off thanks so much for listening
to the dojo
so true funny how it seems